tanto era poi sono partiti in questo
momento amici non è vero non siamo in
live
non siamo in lei ma che ne so io non
faccio mica vicenda ciao ragazzi tutto
bene allora non so quanto ci stiamo
vedendo io chiediamo una persona che sa
di layla ma quando parti con la live
come fai a salutare persone che non ti
caga nessuno appena partita che sarà
infatti mettono un loghino che gira così
perché nel mentre non per non sentirmi
sono e mi guardi anche male c'è anche
campo nonché ei terzi in italia docet
ragazzi siamo il live dopo una vita in
mezzo che non faceva largo alla porta
che non si chiude moriremo ricato va
dentro sai mio caro hayter volevo dirvi
che oggi uscito sea of thieves e sono
con londra ragazzi ragazzi poi c'è anche
ciao ciao
lei non deve parlare pietro le parole
ciao su tutti sono date che sono fiero
e poi c'è anche pietro ovviamente c'è
anche
com che qua vicino va beh iniziamo
costano sia fisiche e l'ho aspettato per
26 anni e mezzo io tra l'altro sto
giocando da l'xbox voi state giocando al
computer atg pc gamer
ci siamo almost forma sto allora vado è
in teoria se proprio questo tasto magico
tala apparso nascar mamma mia immagine
di sé le spetterà che c'è una intro che
io non ho visto qualche già visto quindi
attendete 1 al second che la guardo
insieme ai ragazzi che non ho visto
ancora niente e poi partiamo mai siete
ciao ragazzi ciao a tutti quelli che
sono appena con esse si sta giocando la
l'xbox one knicks ragazzi aspetta su
tutto riva i vostri file perché mi piace
allora noi cominciamo bene
viaggi in compagnia di una fedele c
ormai chiamato da federer ma più o meno
all'ora ma sicuro federer non può venire
allora fedelissimi
[Musica]
male gli altri viaggiano voci
come allora allora allora dài la
smentita
[Musica]
non ha certo non trattabile chiamata
diego è tutto in rima di gatta
[Musica]
dice
e ad atena dea
della terra
atene la città qualche cosa ok ci siamo
ragazzi affidata in troppo noti diavolo
gli stormi e io purtroppo non lo ritrae
nemici ma che certo bisogna aggiungersi
agli amici ok allora come faccio ad
accettare il tuo invito carissimo pietro
allora vi invito tutti quanti anni alla
ok perché sono cattivo
eccolo qua partecipa sia of thieves
quanto mi piace perfetto o si crea un
personaggio solo quello così non mi poi
non userò ri possono utilizzarla skin
dall'altra volta quella perfetta ma sto
venendo ora hai un secchissimo
maglioncino blu fashion blogger ma c'è
anche da uomo lo sapevo io vi ho detto
sei un pirla
è bello così renata pirlatti allora
siamo sulla schermata di selezione
personaggio ma allora il personaggio che
mi segue vogliono tenere per sempre
eh sì diciamo non puoi cambiare è un
momento epocale fondamentale se dicono
pronti bene non è meglio che sei tu a
sceglierlo ma il personaggio che
sceglierete decrepito che brutta figura
emergendo quei senza mani senza mai ne è
uscito il tipo coi baffi ha tirato senza
così sicuro
che bello in italiano ok
direi che potete inviare invitati
c'erano e non vi ho tra gli amici amico
perfetto magari tu vai su ebay su xbox
che di gioco poi vai su xbox cacchio ii
e schiacci sudate che partecipa a ok
allora devo farlo io intanto mi devi
aggiungere più e mi serve il nome anche
hanno scritto sono io il nome e cognome
non fa parte non è vero ma che arrivano
tipi calore non mi è arrivato
assolutamente niente poi tanto sono sul
l'xbox box insider mano dove l'indotto
ad esso avrebbe rivolto inoltre
distillery perché via basso un attimo
che eravate troppo adesso è arrivato da
utilizzare sia artisti per la computer
dovrebbe essere un problemino questa
roba ma è minder farti minuto da in
gioco pietro non posso non ero mai
chiude il gioco thomas e ripropone
faccia accettare l'invito vi prego
i nostri due supereroi prof
ormai che c'è con poche grazie tv tv tv
ma tra poco ma quante volte io per
entrare laga ci siamo la cosa più
difficile è stata fatta cammino ciao
amici anche assoluto ham non sono
l'ultimo che non perdiamo funziona a
livello di audio e sentono ci sentiamo
livelli uguali
pietro è proprio una mega meglio mi
sentite bene raga io si questiona
benissimo mancava un call
partiamo da ecco non mi vedete in gruppo
non sono se non sento il primato adesso
è stato nel dito rientrare ballo aspetto
aggiungendo che sto inviando un invito
io so il vostro bardot ragazzi di mangia
che per noi mangiarini marmi che magra
tree e liste assumendo loro qualcosa ho
trovato ora da ora dovrebbe abbraccia
una certa ora appena entrati chimica
clicchiamo al prendiamo di laurea ma che
è pietra si manda via
ma mi sta imitando gli approfonditi si
no questo è il largo del degli inviti di
sea of tears ha idea di come togliere
eterno tipico d'acqua stiamo giampaolo a
rischio
una curiosità come credo che il rumore
come si vede che credo acqua pura del
diario di bordo
manca molto entrare aperture da diario
di bordo mi dice credo che saranno nel
nostro gruppo ma perché pensiamo dove
studiare quindi un po ci sono i pezzi
diodoro sopra design sposi un peso
specifico abbastanza elevato messaggi
eviti di pietro che sanno farlo i
ragazzi
ma allora se ti invita le feste non sta
riuscendo veramente le entrate lo ri
accetto da dentro il gioco guarda di
allora una partita sì
[Musica]
dietro state di sta installando gli
inviti a ciò che dico di sì il gruppo si
può imitare qualcun altro perché io
faccio la mia per il gioco e rimane
rimane l'attimo di perché pietro non lo
vuole tra gli amici ma poi però fare il
gruppo roma radio ma qualcuno inviti al
dai serbi e meno dove vai dagli amici te
lo giuro 1 a lino
[Musica]
isner ving bene presento guardiamoci
negli occhi mentre che noi mentre che
tom ragazza che farei a te lo giuro non
danno un pacco strada
stavamo tutti aspettando il ritorno di
ortiz da mille anni siamo arrivati al 20
di marzo ros data prescelta è ovviamente
thomas mann entra
è un problema
[Musica]
quanti di voi che stanno seguendo la
lypas pignotti yo yo yo di opera non
sapere anche tu volevi giocanti talmente
anche intanto scherzo tra l'altro
comunque volevo dirvi che nell'attesa
dietro lo fai perché sono bello mi è
andato mi han dato queste robe che sono
i gadget di sea of thieves ed è un
tatuaggio fake che mi sono messo ed e
figli ma non è vero che lo no però come
volevo fare si trova in saltate una roba
abbastanza easy e cioè che ora ce l'ho
fatta quindi questa frase non mi è nuova
ai fatta si è entrato dentro si può
giocare non incredibile bravo tom il
gioco giochiamo
ma pietro capitano nora gravi per il
capitano e qui cena non ben onda
tranquillo non era lui poi firmare il
capitano adesso andiamo nove ragazzi
possiamo evitare di rubare denaro e poi
salpare senza gli altri sicuro grazie
mille luchetti mimica favore ma siccome
tipo non lo farei mai lo andrei io a
farlo però sono tipo in cuffia toe due
volte e nono sfrutta la maggiore mietres
vanno trattati così a giuseppe esatto
questo così
perché faccia che aveva fatto due video
con te incroci di cui uno quello basta
marchiato a vita ha segnato per sempre l
iter ho fatto 15 milioni di views
rumorino vieni io so fare la pasta è
buona la pasta è vero l'ho lasciata
digiuno gli ho detto vieni che mangiamo
l'ha guardata buona io mando solo per me
la pasta forse è meglio così campo dai
ragazzi noi siamo io ci siamo io sono
dentro non vi sto caricando miope
donnino
sì sono io sto entrando mitch non è vero
sto caricando ancora tante entro ok dal
3 è cambiato anche i caricamenti
bellissimo aspetta aspetta non va via
nino massei nudo ma che figata
come sono nudo è nudo
magari stesso giovane fare il mio
equipaggio
l'equipaggio aspetta che ti muto
immediatamente il primo mio villaggio
efsf il primo no una nave o meno quella
un'altra cosa possiamo fare quando
pietro è solo strano vela fondiamo
questo segni audio potevo scrivere
attivo maggio bene mentre dar
ma perché siete tutti nudi scusatemi il
signore vi ricordo che quando ero bassi
legno con le riprendono le banane
le banane e che si parla allora ragazzi
di finanza che sta sparando pallone non
sono io
ragazze che certe sulla rai ha visto
ancora 600 sulla nato un attimo del
dolce dentesano strana tantissimo la
sonda vado a prendere ma chiedetelo a me
bayern
metti in moto il compagno voce ok molto
tutti quanti scusate almeno parata di st
ok senso poiché la legge tendente al a
me per come sapeva partigiano del posto
credo non si affaccia proprio da
indigeno quindi vieni torino vede roma
per la spada voi ora è vero tempio a
starmi dei ragazzi che si è evitato lori
ma non è con la gara dalla madre che si
è buttato c'è uno squalo stiamo andando
a scuola
attualmente se ne stanno rotella lo devo
prendere le missioni immagino vado a
prenderle prima che ci ritroviamo in
mare senza missione con dentro è dentro
la vedo che persiste nel voler dire non
aver ucciso lo ha ucciso
che bello sempre super mila grazie mille
everest a testa passava con vado a
cambiarmi un attimo perché se mi prende
per il culo
non so come coloro della saga me la
gioco del jazz a di problemi o mio dio
certo prendere la torcia farei così
prima con l'account pagare la mattina in
di contro non sono invece allarme
possibile no no ma sono qui da questo
tasto per equipaggiare con mela dei
video quali sono non ce l'hai subito
avete racconto di ciò the april armeria
si può che nessuno intorno nave ti
[Musica]
comporti non sono stupido io non ho mica
di default la squadra che non ce lo dirà
no no no non ci non le puoi qui poggiare
telai subito dai andiamo io non sparate
voi e asmar piacevole mettiamo sul
tavolino allora avete già preso e mi se
fatemi vedere un attimo le emissioni
[Musica]
grazie
pane
l'avete già presa ma proprio le missioni
per cose che non ho mai pietro per
niente
eri il calciatore e prendo io se volete
sono un po già quali il malloppo
malloppo depredato le patetico di qua
che prenderà altro
[Musica]
le note
resterà la mia macchina
[Applauso]
bene abbiamo generalista per quale mi
vedevo l'ora mi mancava questo
giustissimo ottimo molti mondiale
previsto anno dove l'ha visto che ci
porta aspetto a cui di piero europa
hanno alzato leggermente i prezzi
michele stai la kaim ha detto io non so
come mai coltivato burqa è questa la
cosa che si può persona amante what
vinto quattro volte
dov'è che sono le persone in questione è
quella lì esatto è fatto che è ficcata
incredibile bellissimo
ebbene veramente figo erba dopo tanto
quanto ciò spostando la faccia scarpi è
quasi una forte dell'asta spetta vale a
dire che possiamo dire vai io scherzavo
nella specie perché ci sentiamo sappiamo
speriamo solo ancora se avremmo giurato
resti come un dito questo si no
miope della mia energia cinetica è
altissima in questo momento abbiamo
andiamo via tutti che sta al timone non
c'è qualcuno che pensa e pietro è dentro
c'è pietro attivazione la missione
bianco sotto la missione eccola sappiamo
proprio votarla che vi giuro sede rai
montante dell'arma non ne usciamo
andiamo andiamo
qualcuno mette la missione che permette
di penso io l'amavo ragazzi morti
popolazione contro i mancava l'aria
qualcuno è il fattore m io e ora manca
manca ancora un buon voto per la
missione
io io metto io per fermarci a pensare
che stia facendo la stessa nuzzolo
accumulato dal patetico ma che collega
la targa come si facevano utilizzare
ecco l'arma delle i pali le cose con
miei figli tino bino ma bisogna andare a
sud ovest mio capitano
allora spiego a tutti quanti per chi non
conoscesse si hopkins è praticamente è
un gioco di bambine ma macchine bisogna
arrivare quando lei gli altri
bisogna suonare si suona così grossi ma
nient'altro che questo si gioca e si
sole massa beh basta esatto non ci piace
assieme con meno è il gioco di di pirati
che qui non permettendo nudi tra l'altro
che parte c'è una mappa sulla scena ma
no ma no è colpisce il bersaglio cioè
devi tirare pugni di in quel punto ho
capito questo nuovo cell
[Musica]
volevo dire gioco dove ci sono siamo
pirati dopo che parigi le altre navi se
non troviamo alcune però cervino pietro
ballo da nessuno e dobbiamo trovare la
chiave d'oro nascosti nelle queste
questa estate vi dico anche da gelato
dovremo approcciare shark bay è un
titolo di youtube
[Musica]
allora mi sento e poi l'altra per favore
ci si faccio io faccio direi
ora va benissimo
i dati fidati adesso
cannone vorrei pero io non so dire
questa traccia di questi prodotti
porca vacca non è questa il supermercato
e lanciatevi siamo rimasti un sacco vado
storms e l'anci che purtroppo è l'albero
non è così entro prego anche quadrati di
mano già mera sul tesoro mettiti in
questo tipo di per una parte di questo
perché per chiederle sono stanco che
trattiene pietro no no c'è solo andato
quello che ho visto partire mi sono
sentito un tipo dall'altro pone rai dove
si affilano avevo anch'io bene mentre
prima gli eredi guardie trono lui io no
non lo so leggere stampa dove siamo è
così ed è che giusto sì ma qualcuno è
aumentato il tesoro e proprio fa miss
aspetta
ancora tra nave perché non mi sa che
proprio quando è a sud
e qua ragazzo e sono io che noi siamo ma
io non ero bravo
no questo pro loco dove l'attrice starmi
stato riferito che le permette di
abbassare dovete usare il flauto magico
aiuta lo fa rotolare livello ha detto
trovato non è il flauto mostra su questo
per venini funzionalista grazie possiamo
passare adesso allora reese nord
non ho ben capito dove sulle vendite
domenico da quelle due le forze mancava
dall altro io seguo voi perché l'ho
sempre trovato gli ho detto che stavolta
non trovo la mafia che non ho capito che
siamo mai pietro facci tu da cicerone
neanche di 100 per cento dice la nota
molto appealing tecnicamente di ottimo
facciamo maiale ai maiali anno se non
dovessimo è chiaro che le gore imperia e
quando non la gamma si confida il maiale
nostri risparmi primo perché qua trovato
un forzato per il festival a cascata
sulla misura si può prenderla carne di
mike lino racconto cuore e 9 no
è stata ora sto guardando la cascata il
fai vedere la fai vedere pietro
come vede la mappa e allora questa però
23 siamo esattamente
dobbiamo andare noi a davide il canzone
quindi la mira capezzolo che aspetta
pugliesi sud e est e ragazzi da questa
parte non essere nella parte più interna
della parte più esterna che interna da
parte mia storia
grazie noi seguiamo e dovrebbe essere
tipicamente usato la forza di mimmo io
non sono un pilota esperto
io secondi in calcoli da jack farlo un
altro giorno al tracollo deve essere in
teoria dovrebbe essere più o meno ho
scheletri alla grande divario resta
caverna lasciando magari perché la
caverna e questa ha detto scavo la trama
ragazzo dovrebbe essere qua tipo io vi
leggo da controllare diamo un pò
fototipo qua io ho controllato sono
bravi viste cose capisco forza ragazzi
scavate uomini scavate io non è quasi
come se ascoltiamo loro ma tu hai
trovato una casa dove altri per terra
grazie va bene che somiglia tantissimo
un'altra isola ma non è questa l'isola
no no e questo dovrebbe essere qua ve lo
giuro insomma capace segnato che qua
questo è il nord a fare da stormi che ha
lasciato che io ho solo un problema come
sia per la mappa non l'ho ancora capito
lo hanno trovato due pensatemi mese come
siamo ridotti se vai vai via e scappa
simile ma lo è il brano è fissa c'è
qualcosa che non va in questo momento
veramente bravo era la cosa più semplice
dove la nave la nave non lo so ma c'è
uno nudo che correva io sono aiuto ma
sono davvero non mettevo il mostro
vedere il miur anonimi se non lo so c'è
stata reazione a dalla parte opposta
dice ragazzi sono stati armati e io sono
occupato con via vigevano a trovare la
nave ragazzi e chi gli chiede se uccisi
a eccola la nave la vede per farlo
andiamo andiamo bene ok doveva restare a
vista beh qualcuno porta questo barile
di esplosivo così se ci stanno e non
funziona così lo re e non lo lasci la
ragazza che sono io ci sono delle casse
con del 3 delle cose utili per la nave
se volete prenderle forse
prendete pure vediamo riesco a parte una
banana presunto andiamo da che ha preso
il barile ed esplosivo che ci possa
servire magari perché fare il comico
giusto durante la nostra esplorazione
c'è anche il porcellino nero come tesori
ragazzi non è come nella beta che i
tesori che non rimangono questi
rimangono vogliono nave bella io quindi
perfetto ma ragazzi andiamo subito a
svenderlo che fa tesoro eppure lo
teniamo però questa missione duplice a
due isole da dobbiamo andare per finirla
per avere loro ottimo quindi bisogna
dare sulla seconda sì sì ci sono due
mappe adesso cosa la prima abbiamo fatto
di colori esperto di capirlo è giocata
una anche se ti ami ti sarà comandato di
provarlo fonte la prima volta giocato un
po pieno
va bene attenzione a questa morente di
caldo è recato lo giuro caldo morente
eccoci qua a fini dico al capitano dove
andare vediamo un po che grazie stai
facendo pietro se no stop abbassandole
conto che se non lo so registrare
precedentemente ha tratto se guardi la
mappa cela dietro la schiena e
vendutissimo diretta questa dove
vogliono fare no non so se questo nuovo
e non posso nord nord est mio capitano
[Musica]
ma sono morto beschi e discorsivo pietro
ma abbiamo perso tutto il tesoro
la nave ancora lì ci ricorda sopra no
sempre no per cento abbiamo perso ma
ragazze non abbiamo perso niente per
finire cresce che ha ucciso il nostro
modello di stato pietro uccide tutti
se non fossi air
sempre tenendo dietro qua ma non possono
lavare a correre verso niente e non ci
che non ti meriti risultati mettiamo lo
metterà un piacere e vediamo poi ci
abbiamo ancora siamo gli abbiamo fatto
noi avremo più la nave abbiamo mandato
via pure ci sono stato l'esclusione
nucleare ma la stiva vorrete messo sotto
come fai a dimettere come è vero ho
votato per mettere pietre prigione se
volete per dentro quando c'è chi ha
messo a fare questa cosa aspetta che mi
dà suono è assolutamente zona sua del
preferisco 9 queste le briciole ma va
bene va bene è caduto cella a preferì ha
preferito l'ammutinamento bravo piano
taylor destra il liquido nei visceri 8
va bene adesso che abbiamo tolto la
zavorra anni
dobbiamo andare vediamo nella valle
napoli e su come l'acqua pietro
sai dove sembra l'altro in poi gli altri
dove dovremmo andare per trovare trina
che questa è a stiamo andando
esattamente li sente is less grazie
perché bellissimo inglese stoner che ci
occupiamo lì davanti va bene allora m
l'altro punto coordina la prevenzione
del 6 con le mani dietro la schiena come
i vecchi al cantiere zio possiamo chino
a sinistra le belle ragazze per avere
più mento ragazzi ma avete fruttato ben
più vero per un giro e non sta
funzionando con un po di buchi lega se
non avrebbero davvero no ma dai di
mandache ragazzi lasciato il team e
voglia di fare a piedi ma qual è stato
sei scemo quello scemo scemo e scemo e
scemo quello madonna se non c'ero io
titanic ma sei pazzo ma questo è pazzo
spende fosse scappare una roba
incredibile ma non penso 4
questa regola dei list degli scheletri
reja ma e devi stare andiamo a trovare
pietra grigia carica
con la sigla del report
sì ma non siamo con la giusta adesso
tira su la imparare tutto a posto
tu sei pietro ti veniva quindi le carte
cina triste 6 divertenti
sei divertito marra tanto lo so che
quindi spediti ma con cura
[Musica]
li lascerei una moneta volentieri ma non
c'è manco guerra perché qualcuno ce
uccise però non puoi neanche uscire
volevo perché sono gli è stato lui
ancora non ha capito e sicurezza
allora se prima il suo paio di
schiacciare z kg premuto z e poi ti spot
è una volta io al posto
migliore
si era preso dalla lancio mi dici crisi
false si trovi principale morte
[Musica]
diventare verde sul turno di liberarmi
stai zitto pietro se in prigione senza
facili ma bravissimi seguita [ __ ] e
allora non è l'uomo più o meno buona
cosa per via e grazie precisione tutto
l'amore del mondo faccio io grazie di
millenaria mandiamo ma pietro lo
possiamo tirar fuori oppure no aspetta
eccolo trovato l'auto siediti dormi con
lo stato almeno su
vado
una cosa veramente orribile
vedendo però va bene così è veramente
una cosa per questa questa però faccio
per i cortei testa adesso che è tutto a
essere quasi di strano 101 dorino di
provola che fa paura va bene ma venite a
vedere che succede nella foto per caso
quando scrivevano che non sto vedendo
niente protesta amici è una bella cosa
perché era allenato una donna è quello
vadano solo amici quella per i figli per
i liberi e liberiamo pietro ci pensava
liberiamo signori io non votate
liberazione ma manca il mio voto
dovrebbe confermare o ribaltare gli
sbarchi quindi potrei tenerlo lì dentro
io sono cuore bisogna andare a scarta
fatemi guardare un pochino più a nord
way teme che salpa with the mark clark
nord quindi aspetta
ma no loren a nord sono irrisorie
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
grazie non ci aveva indicato cortesini
un po nord e dovrebbe essere quel
isolotto tra poco ce l'abbiamo davanti
ancora un pochino di più a sinistra
diciamo perché anche ci stiamo andando
ci stiamo a proposito nella final beta
del gioco c'era una specie corale alla
brutta
la nuvola una diversa andiamo chiusi tre
dentro ci siete dentro e lo dice
salvatore piede ed esaltante ancora in
prigione navi in giro ce ne sono delle
navi in giro da quel che vedo con la mia
vista talenti ma non vedo cosa abbiamo
trovato una persona sola vostra nave
subito a caso e non ci sono ma è meglio
così direi allora fate dovrebbe essere
quella l'isola no non ancora
no no no io d'asta abbiamo andare
aspetta chi è che stati monale io ho
fatto una corsa a vedere le ragazze sono
allora ci serve pietro era timonare
separate che va bene chicken isla perché
occhio che c'è una c'è un bosco ios che
noi finiamo come dita di aggirare le
mele ragazzi a sinistra tempo è stato
rilasciato dalla cella aspetta che
ripara un po la nave com è una
detenzione incredibile sia stato un
siffatto vicino a te compreso tra amici
di un suicidio
qualcuno mi conferma la benedizione non
sono stati sì non lo so ai miei di
sollievo dare al no a destra dicono che
ormai non è questa destra adesso invece
quando vai a destra è completamente
adesso vai a destra stesso completo a
ginevra tutta dal piano piano guarda che
guarda che ubriachi qualche giro abbiamo
fatto solamente
bisogna citare le mele pagati agire
rinato talmente lori vivace del e viene
presentata più veloci e aspetta che devo
capire quando vice linee chiamo a est il
movimento con trissino il vento si
rimanda resto è pieno non vedo davanti a
me però ragazzi che abbiamo davanti non
è vero io abbiamo non abbiamo abbiamo
abbiamo gira tanto gira fortore quanto
da che direzione mare e non sono capace
dalle indicati sinistra deve stare a
destra fatto tenendosi sia adesso perché
andava adesso abbiamo soppresso mega
scoglio valestra gli raggiera gentile
durante a destra dove siamo adesso
ragazzi e mini sta offrendo delle vele
mentre no non posso andarci a sbattere
contro col vento incontro veneto deve
passare il giro largo poi girare a
ingaggiare ragazza cosa dicono questi
ragazzi cos'è quella nuvola con
scheletro sopra ci andremo mai società
destra insomma giusto adesso
esatto e adesso dovrebbe essere giusta
ti dico che quando per marchini a destra
che potrebbe essere qualcosa di
totalmente non avverso madonna guarda
dove siamo finiti ma ti rendi conto
devi girare ok ancora destra quest
adesso al sud est ha chiesto scogli o
gigantesco lo scoglio
superare bene alle dietro perché dalla
mappa grande non si vede lo score
portato dietro la mappa grande c'è
pietro ubriaco ma la dritta la vedi con
la dritta previsto la vista che averla
vista per fatta riusciamo sarà il vento
siamo in controvento totale mi sa raga
magari valore che è successo è tirato la
ancora che ti rode ancora reja ci sono
meno male l'ha salvata dove solo re lori
che dolore dice dove dove diavolo
recchia è successo cosa succede sono
stato catapultato nel fondo come nel
casi è vero ma non c'e non ero sulla
punta della rai sono sparito dalla
maledizione del testo caso nel teso
questa muoio perché un rischio tornare
arriva al nel bidone non ce l'ha fatta
cioè la maledizione del teschio vista la
mia che mi ha buttato giù dalla nave
visivi a caso è vabbè arrivo con la
supervelocità prenotando stai volando
scuro è vero che qualcuno sta
controllando la mappa vero ragazza io
stavo facendo quello che rimanere in
fondo al mare
siamo se ci siamo ci siamo e fonda ma
roma ma noi siamo andati a destra
sinistra destra sinistra che era
vicinissimo era vicinissimo l'isola e
arriviamo anche senso andare veloci
dritti quando si può fare un giro ma se
questa santa teresa lanciate mi chiedo
se il gioco è gratis
no si compra su tutto scudo adesso
dietro tutto giocare e quella li ha
notati che mi dia la tua destra con gli
altri ragazzi sera questo è un gioco
quindi è un giappone madonna è un gioco
molto molto bello se è un giocone se non
ci fosse pieno ci siamo siamo aiutati
ragazzi accorsi a organo produttivo di
cane non lo sa ma io prima a scendere a
sanare questa dire vai dritto
chi è che non ci sono iscritti dritto a
destra giro alla vela e così via più
veloci valori tre errori pietro vai
dritto fidati di loro i loro nomi grazie
poi entra dentro un qualsiasi cannone
espressa aspetto che giriamo e giriamo e
giriamo sei pronto alla detonazione la
intimi no sono queste quale isola giusto
tre spari e un partito che bella questa
mappa porca vacca che regala lo stato
non buttarla così a caso non bottone
grazie siamo arrivati macchiarola perché
la persona è stata ispirativo aspiranti
lante perché qualcuno mi spara io io ci
vuole
rispondiamo potrebbe essere un problema
nel dubbio si mise la centrale
quello che ragazzo incontra i ragazzi
fanno piacere i serpenti giocando
insieme giocare con voi io paura ho
paura di pietro gli sparò da solo
stormy
ok morto gigantesco no date di pietro
questa l'isola giusta forse quasi a
scavare ciao pietro
sono in mezzo al mare chi che ha sparato
e orbi tutto questo ho paura ci sono
degli squali che mi insegnò tu sei
qualche signorina aiuto attraverso
dall'altra parte del di questa isola
allora salita ci sono delle caverne che
ti portano dalla parte opposta in teoria
dovremmo riuscire ad arrivare che belli
porcellini e poi la battuta occhiale
addirittura no non la faccio ciò per te
in cima si bisogna salire in cima e gira
aspetta siamo ragazze che non riesco a
trovare dovrebbe essere tipo egli però
non so se sono oggi non si dovrebbe
essere tipo qua se non sbaglio rotocol
sorprende ma la porta ma lo zio ovvio
aiuto ma invece di continuare a caso è
di una punta
allora dei punti di riferimento dove sei
sopra ben tre le caverne in teoria
turistici non è coraggio che parlo
trovato credo allora se non erro credo
che sia molto vicina mi trovo io
inviterei a venire nord e quel è siamo
qua dove dove siamo gli stormi in teoria
il nord e quello a destra vediamo
quell'isola lì quindi signoria di pietro
ti lancio una cosa pieni voti se no ti
deve se non prendete pietro vedrebbero
superata no non c'è un annuncia loro
lancia ballo non dovrebbe essere qui
dove sei tu sai tipo dovevano per terra
prova a scavare vede niente
com'è come lascio il forziere trova
occhio che ci ha occhio agli occhi
dietro
ragazzi estate fu lo sguardo
siamo qui ma non credo questo cosa hai
trovato hai trovato noi provvisorio 3
culo non è quello no non è quello dove
quello di collegamento e basta ma mi sa
che sei un passo sopra possibile dove
sono io caso si scava perché il gioco è
appena uscito ci stiamo parlando a
rimini ma dalla parte opposta rispetto a
questa è no io ho guardato sulla bussola
è a 9 maggio si dice poi controllare che
non sulla bussola nord quindi dovrebbe
essere qui da qualche parte non so dove
secondo me è sopra lino dove delle star
e su quanto è stato io
come fai il bravo vai pietro sogni a
cura di certi media dei consigli a
giusto sono esperto e non farglielo
trovare la mia pietro di nuovo per
favore e solo tra pietro e mi sa che c'è
vicino molto vicino ma no perché quella
è la partizione sono messi non cilindro
sotto ha ragione ed ecco scheletri
scheletri qualcuno mi dovrebbe
non vera mi vieni qua ma se per te
l'avevo visto ma mai nella mia bene ve
lo giuro vabbè avete visto mia
striscione gli artisti mi trovo tutti io
mo li trovi di pietro e impulsi sono in
live
decide così com'era com'è che
normalmente non fa impegno e 4 di tutto
penso però gli asini neri voglio dire
qualcosa
i simboli invece l'ha scritto nascoste
cose agli spartans dei che ci sono delle
registrazioni calavena no è meglio non
farsi mancare assolutamente a persone
tra vita con meta vitality marino sono
fortissimi e la coltellata 1 prima del
suo back
tutto questo abbiamo quattro tesori se
non avessi becca è un problema è sentito
un organo punto potremmo andare a vergin
dalle signore o vogliamo rischiare ma
potremmo in torino 3 euro
possiedo ragazzi ma quella cosa laggiù
in fondo la nave o sbaglio a sarebbe
sarebbe alla nostra sinistra vicino
all'isolotto
il cuore così andrea vendere così
possiamo in missione da questa è finita
perché non ci sono dimissioni non ci
sono
assicuriamo che una fortezza sicuro
bisignano fortezza la classica fortezza
che sta a lato o no nove ragazzi puro
che vedete al sicurezza nella figura
però come lascia la stanza casse non
ottenendo xxxx mannaggia ora che c'è una
c'è un forziere nascosto nel cioè spero
che ci siano delle amarene sbavava
facciamolo tremolante dei vetri ma devo
sfavore sì perché nella renault thriller
prima pietra
no a che alla fine del mese dritta lo
giuro ma non ho detto dritto e bastone
non ne sono di vento ragazzi cavoli
dritte dritte siamo signori vai pietro
bartolo tom sta tirando ancora il
rituale con stormi si ha troppo pesante
ma che mai immaginato
era troppo pesante dov'è il relitto
signori sinistra
il relitto mi spiace pietro mari lesione
lele ma siamo arrivati non gira gira
gira gira ragazzi gira gira a sinistra
per favore navi ancora non abbiamo visto
che abbiamo una spero niamo è tutto non
potremmo che logicamente regista dietro
aspettano nostro sacro pregava cosa sono
queste bene lo ha detto a sinistra cos'è
la formosa è questa nella sua
dimenticata sim e potente siamo fieri di
questo momento realismo controvento di
relitto e poi davanti a noi a si gira
proprio caso forza ragazzi vieni lori
che ti sparo sul relitto vinicola spiega
io sono sopra debuttanti sono la campana
galla ancora ancora ancora ancora penso
io penso io la butto la butto noi siamo
ad hoc lori vieni qua che ti sparano
vieni vieni there are scorso era proprio
sul reddito pur cavaco sbagliato staff a
spider pasquale talmente ho trovato un
modo più rapido per scendere una busta
nando ti sta facendo proprio il dio
parkour sulla sulla barca è bellissimo
ok che vedete qua però imparato qui
sotto vento lega vice para mi chiamo
vediamo effetto del 6
non so come come sovrappeso lo sapevo io
bene anche troppo in guardava bene anche
bravi in realtà ragazzi la peculiarità
di questo gioco e poter suonare quindi
io io che chi non vorrebbe si intenderà
con la musica ma l'entrata nel relais
sotto c'è sopra nel senso cioè sopra
sotto diciamo ergo non ho diretto un
visione storica qui sono due tesori e o
un teschio arrivo lingua vita diventi
novellino si predica premi aspetta
famiglie delle famiglie finale c'è anche
una bolla d'aria come respirare
è mario quale sia il costo del
portellone
oddio primo raccogli cucinare ci stanno
attaccando ragazzo pirla mi sono
campioni tipo sono cosa sia
vabè vieni vieni su pietro non ho capito
dove rimane sono due portieri un teschio
e io forse rimane chiuso riprendessero
anch'io ho trovato una casa di spezie
formidabile contro le spezie che cos'è
abbiamo trader e fai vedere non lo sai
cos'è
non vediamo stasera sia abbiamo le
spetti torni questo arrivano piacevole
challenger regalo ce la giocheremo per
mente diciamo bait sulla nave rebate
andiamo andiamo dietro un attimo che
respiro
torniamo giusy io vedere estrae l'arma
di fare cassa disprezzi addirittura
sopra chi lo spezia che se si esatto le
puoi vendere dividere la stanza più
falsa
noi non mettiamo giù se ci assaltano la
nave sarà per i nostri fan ci sono
signori sarebbe un rigore ma quanti
titoli ha dovremmo forse andare un
attimo di vendere perché se manco solo
io questo eden loro ci garanzia era
giusto il mio trono c'era ancora sotto
guardare ancora ai questo il teschio
sera ci sono anch'io come siete
noi siamo qui abbiamo preso dei tagli
diventano attori a il teschio la propria
correggere
possiamo utilizzare per computer
su scrivanie di c intanto lo metto qua
arrivo arrivo alla iii arrivando così
andiamo a venderle che abbiamo un botto
i robot abbiamo incredibile sarebbe un
peccato se ora no lo metto quasi un
letto a dormire
ok no è una data che diciamo forse ha in
mano sarebbero peccato se ci fossero le
maracas più veloce non riesco a
respirare non ci cacciano fatto non ci
sono navi rack e tutto calmo
loris e facciamolo riguarda vieni
qualora i limiti o un altro tesoro
spartano rilasciamo guardare come
facciamo questo ok io mi occupo della
guida diciamo ok ok
mamma mia no perché sta partendo la nave
dove sta andando
ci hanno rubato una nave nor agata per
ragazzo trovato la nave niente ragazzi
ma dovrebbero solo su star di loro ma
dai davvero siete lasciati qua dentro un
corpo perfetto e non avevo capito il
piano risparmi fino a che cosa siamo
partiti adesso l'ho capito grande esatto
ciao la macchina del quale abbiamo
piaceva solo questa ma dentro di loro
forse è ora di sganciare dietro andare
del mirmidoni ma forse erano schiacciamo
dai 2000 direzione di viola destra e 9
non puoi non puoi non puoi prendere la
strada vicinale destra ragazzi ai
tornelli daniel meade onestà tentato è
trovato a crediti per diritti ora siamo
venuti in tanti volti problema il
problema è che ci mette un'ora fino alla
sua nomina della prossima magari non
giocate con la sony come arrivare è
stato troppo bello o cielo scusiamo
scuola da ragazzi e forse speriamo vi
ammazzo no no no no in mare con gli
squali
mentre morto pietro è morto si sente
quello che volevo sentire dov'è che
siete fuori e ci devo provare e workshop
e non vi vedo pensa che non vi vedo
neanche troppo a destra
io i figli guardate non riesco a vedermi
allora io non capisco come rivaldo
detemir minore non vedo lo squalo di
invece vede forzieri ok è
inquietantissimo ma mi ha preso e le
proprie anch'io ti stiamo vedendo anche
qualche un pochino più alla vostra
destra un pochino di pochissimo anche
mirmidoni riprenderci al volo noi non ci
fermiamo ci sono i forzieri potete
prendermi una ragione in realtà poi
sapere portieri e lasciarli giù e
lasciare loro jules mista per uccidere
no no arriviamo a mi ha ucciso
mi avete visto no no abbia visto no però
però grazie a dio davanti non sulla nave
by gucci è vado a prendere mai a fare
fermiamoli buttala ancora i mutui rampl
ha avuto io l'ho ucciso dai miei amici
mamma mi ha veramente credibile tradito
porca vacca mi sa che ho fatto una
carriera mi sa che se si investirà gol
guai a chiamata che fruttano incontro
con pietro
devo andare devo andare solo a noi
vogliamo chiamo io sono bacino è morto
no non è morto vista secondo morto ord
che problemi hai legato di morte mi ha
allevato metà vinta con ep e non avevo i
proiettili capito c'è è stato
bruttissimo stiamo sulla nave non so
dove siete
parole che cambiano di tre quattro
cinque sei sette tesori e 11 è un bene
abbiamo mai avuto così tanti bisogni
familiari va bene allora siamo abbia
fatto di ci andiamo all'audi vostre
galaniano al diretto allora aspettatelo
segno io avamposto ance sbaglia così che
abbiamo anche un po aria in corso dove
vantano coordinante capitolo
direttamente ad est dritto tutto il
paese che mostra le mele ancora ancora
no ricamatrici sono il nero di carattere
ce la facciamo una benvenuta vieni
dentro beve un bicchiere
ecco come si fa bene il ragazzo come si
fa a prender casa devi fornire di grock
ragazzi come si prende come si dice è di
via idee dove ci sono le ho quindi
andiamo tutti a sinistra le belle
ragazze diamo a girarle tesi negli
orrori ci stiamo occupando
esatto la camera ha aiutati quelle blu
ne regala live poteri guardarvelo anche
più avanti tanto da rimane sul canale
per quelli che devono andar via di tutto
quirino pro tanto sto bicchiere hai
capito non devono morire e poi scopriamo
no a noi beviamo noi prendiamo la
visione filosofia vita bene ho pianto
amica ma non vi preoccupate mamma
abbiamo la come vedo una mappa quando
sono riapriamo la branca e danza storia
che si capisca che ha tracciato la scala
storm a città scala scarpa è centrata
bravissimo io non sto toccando niente il
cardinale scola riguarda le sta
camminando attorno il massimo ma solo da
capire loro fa la sua non so che c'è una
bozza per rimanere ancora caduto giù nei
topi si commette infatti aiuto
prenditi un po dell'interno che dietro
questi però di quanti non quelli se la
devi stare lasciare la tua sinistra
e per per fermi e meglio prima lo
capiamo ma va beh volevo l'ancora da
ubriaco la risicati raitre veramente
però la cosa sono tutto un po stare di
comito che mai vista una roba così
orribile basta proprietà ma chi è che
matri lasciato troppo gentile e pieno di
comitato per terra qualcuno pulisca per
farmaco c'è ma è pietro aiello marco
dietro la quale pietro veloci favorire
gli parli di pulire aspetti che pulisca
non è questo lo strumento secchiello da
un'idea una buona idea aspettate quindi
adottare altro in acqua era riprende e
va visto che così impazziamo è una buona
idea buttarsi dalla nave mentre una
festa del giorno si finisce lo so va
bene allora vediamo se in giro c'è
qualcuno che vi sembra incredibile e
arrivato il momento ragazzi ecco una
nave la vedo regalone dove l'avevano
valori dietro di noi fondi per forza
vendere contro 9
ho detto che dietro rino iphone dissi ma
dopo andiamo
c'era c'è un teschio tra l'altro candia
e sentiamo ha ragione d'oro ricarichiamo
le armi palle di camion
io consiglierei
una sterzata ragazzi abbiamo sette
tesori sette tesori vanno persi vai vai
verso la nave e ne frega niente della
perché non la vedono così io la vedo
dov'è allora meglio non lamentatevi di
me a sinistra dietro l'isola che sempre
passare marina dovremmo caricare i
cannoni sono cieco regate lega a quello
è un posto di utilizzo di fianco è da lì
che senza se lo vuole di menare così non
ho una nave te lo dico io però va bene
per consegnare noi non diamo promette
ragazzi carico da un premio nel
frattempo sostegno delle luci che non si
sa mai nel momento alla giacchetta non è
proprio il momento di farsi vedere
ovviamente però sta roba la revoca
rispetto a lei non lo sa se ci affondano
la nave perdiamo tutti dietro un pochino
più ance verso nord di pochissimo pochi
gradi però io ci sarei andato perché
sono un uomo vero lui non vi dico quando
basta
ok va bene così se riesci guardarli come
aspetta solo di essere affondata
guardano guardalà
no sulle vele che dici così non dai
proventi i suoi ragazzi tanto mi sa che
ci siamo ho spento tutte le luci ragazzi
per non farci vedere comunque sì lo vedo
hai fatto valori dove lo rivelano nave a
sinistra c'è uno dove c'è il teschio che
vedo
speriamo non ci invecchino la nuvola
teschio raga non vi dico che cosa c'è
sotto anno va tasche perché sennò non
kit vento abbastanza nel prossimo video
siamo quasi arrivati ragazzi ho paura
veritieri ci attacchino quindi nel
dubbio al sole vele come a dire no che
però veloci perché siamo contro sarei
controvento ma ha studiato bene meglio
se mia madre dice no salvate ti prego di
pietro siamo stiamo andando contro uno
scoglio devi girare signore piacere è un
po così è proprio odio ma c'è una
tempesta è tutto nero non è un bel posto
tutto a sinistra e da sinistra ancora
lavorare stiamo entrando si tipo non
torna dove non è la nebbia ma dove
stiamo andando
siamo vicinissimi ma c'è tipo una
tempesta perché stai vita perché
sfornato del colore un uragano l'abbiamo
un uragano chi la figura destra la
destra la destra pietro guarda con
destra l'ora sia tutto nero blu di
google mi rinfaccia c'è un tornado
signori che il gioco è questo di più
pietro ancora ancora ancora
sì sì sì dalla destra destra ancora
ancora ancora memorabilmente non posso
ottimo ragazzo ora ovviamente a sapete
che è andato dall'avamposto rischiamo di
piacere ma posto è questo
questi sì certo l'ho visto lì non mi
adesso scusate ma è completamente nel ha
chiamato ad essere uno scoglio vanno più
a sinistra se non rientriamo nella zona
nera cioè vi giuro cm ma fidati tirare
fuori un po d'acqua per lo più a
sinistra il rientro con la quanta guarda
poi al casting ma il caldo non è pier
non parlo vinto da fuori quell'acqua che
è difficile parlare vedente ma per la
pioggia si è ragionato insieme carriera
ma sapevo questo
no barnacle che ha detto
sono finiti
siamo quasi manca dietro tutto contro
san pietro luchino più assurdo adesso io
sud est che un evento riguardo
l'avamposto è completamente c'è una nave
erano bosco questo è terribile come idea
no c'è una nave l'avamposto che manda le
vele spiegate se ti muovi la lunga più
veloce dito ritrito velocissimo ragazzi
se mi fate fare figure da pietro il live
view che ammazzo scaricate tutto
dobbiamo andare basta suonare la campana
che fastidio è che sono cieche che il
modo che chi suona km tesoro facciamo
pietro devi fare quello che sai fare
devi fare quello che sai fare city guido
io non sai
ma il punto qualcosa vieni assoluto
controllo alcuno subito raga le
secchiate qui e mi ha l'acqua dalle ave
piena buona ma sta succedendo per niente
perché non possiamo contare su un
continuo su madonna è diventata
difficile da piena tempesta è veramente
difficile da pure il punto finiamolo via
stena devi andare all'avamposto to
pietro ne facciamo questo lo sai vero
una decisione noi si sta attaccando
andando il terribile sta notizia
raga la nave quale noi fa aiuto i
parenti e so che ci penso io mi sto
preparando
ok arrivare dietro ai dritto dritto
dietro tirando via l'acqua un momento
perfetto per questo tipo di vita
basta mandare le via voglio comunque
secondo questa buona
no voglio mercato di niente
prima la boss inseguiamo successo ma
l'uomo a quelle non seguiamo lì sulla
destra pietro destra test a pieni voti
cambiamo le cose pilotare più giorno sei
chiamate va bene allora io farei una
cosa per modo simpatica ma andrei a
vedere la il bio che la difesa il più
amari quest'isola è simpatico schettino
che sta dietro ai ragazzi io non ve lo
giuro non ho mai visto in tutta la mia
vita non ho messi a rilassarmi
affondando da prequel
questo è il peggiore dei parcheggi la
tempesta se ne sta andando poi a
sinistra io mai a destra dritto c'ha
ragione
raga la nave la nave e la potere siamo
andati dritti e quindi sentiamo inteso
arriva prima di perderli le diable
ancora la nave era da accusatorio ma la
cr trovare
è la marcia io so fare i tuoi ministro
paolo letto si parla alzate no a pietro
fivestore di regole voglio affidarmi
affidare allora altre tutte le linee
tranne quella vicino al posto di guida
ok fraschini da sto alzando
ok comunque era gay non ve l'ho detto ma
le altre navi sono altre persone che
giocano in multiplayer ovviamente non ve
l'ho detto ma era scontato altro però
dove si sa mai che non lo sappiate
accantonato solo dove andate
la nave se ne sta andando giustamente
appena di essersi dovuto fare una cosa
bella ma ad arrivare l'anno
i due stare qua devo stare purtroppo
lordi a ora ragazzi vede della miglior
manovra nautica di sempre come vera di
prima diciamo no beh quelli per
artistica dai l'altro non siamo
affondati come ho parcheggiato legate
all'emergenza ma è pietro vediamo la
quasi nazionale mamma mia a ci dicono la
la chat che durante la tempesta si
rompono le riparazioni e per quello
quindi alla fine tutta colpa di pietro
che si era fatto esplodere tre numeri di
rimaste quanti decidere così poi il
sedere della nave
ma cosa c'è allora guarda la perfezione
di questa manovra e mi piacerà ancora
veste stampa ma ora che ci abbiamo una
nave credito per otto mancino tutta la
gelosia è una garza non c'ero guarda qui
quanti buchi ma che fai correre lì e
fare le cose in fra borsa la nostra
miglior ha vinto quindi io avrei voluto
buttare giù un'altra nave no perché
stiamo provando a vendere sopra poi
dedichiamo tutto il tempo e nei vari
ricaviamo una nave davanti da uno e due
per la mirate giù da da dire ma non so
se mandiamo in più veloci sia meno
troviamo lo spirito non l'ha ancora
ragazzino
in europa siamo salvi i saldi sanno che
non hanno capito male
ecco un po di soldi ma lei chi l'abbia
non va giù sbagliate scusate io io sia
quella ancora ok siamo quasi arrivati
finalmente lo sto facendo pietro baio
quello e vedere quanto preciso volete
che io sia faccio vedè abazia logica sia
ancora ancora ancora ancora adesso
ancora adesso ancora prego vendite
sfruttata tv ma guarda che fa che in
giugno grande mostra capitano che vi
edizione guida ragazzi di vedere via
sulle spalle non volevo vedere niente di
tutto ciò poi abbiamo giocabile nostri
cavoli forse allora mi dico la e
giustamente di spostare la webcam per
vedere quanti soldi guadagniamo durante
quest'arco stampa iso curioso di vedere
quanto ci dà per le spezie ma non pensi
possono ben si possono vedere specie
credo di sì per forza forse no ma non
possiamo rimanere in agguato dietro
l'isola attaccare chi viene a
passeggiare tesori un'idea è la stessa
idea che ha avuto il primo che è morto
aveva fatto una bella fine va reagan
amico una volta è morto per consegnare
forziere dove si consegnano si va dai
visi consegnava i temi si l'attore
naufrago 170 della destra ecco 130
regali
big money quasi fanno e simone stelle
parti è una roba che se anche mi sono
perso abbiamo 300 gold e si vede appena
risalito a sinistra 307 aspetta che
mezzo ci sono cori avviamento
io comunque per trovare altre navi
andrea signor e io non ho capito come si
vendono armi riguardarli che girano
volete avendo seguirono vieni qua allora
non credo che le specie si sono ripresi
vedere però il loro atto ma non andava
era forse servono promozione 20 forzieri
delle fiere tratti si può vendere allora
spiega nico ha provato allora quanto mi
stiamo facendo a questa con l'eco del
testo non equa
proviamo a vedere da un altro prima
portare il teschio questa qua il rischio
che che avevi sla pc paro sbaglio tali
organi lo prego
questo quanto noto dicono dalla chat che
il teschio di farcela dopo la mamma mia
il primo ragazzi provati scrive in chat
dove si vende questo questa roba di
spesa dalla chat e vi iscrivete dove si
vende per salutare le sere
l'armaiolo sicuramente no abbiamo
trovato i soldi si compra una volta
civico ma vale se vuoi un fucile a pompa
il cecchino no no no chiaro 1000 1100
1300 quello quando quanto stava nella
beta quanto quando sai quanto corridoio
quell'unica 3d davvero non è vero ma
nella guarda addossato vederlo
scopri le merci e l'armaiolo tutte le
armi non vanno dai 3 di 5 euro
ll schabel e sciabole di quella con
l'ottica rotta 13.000 mazza il vetro
ribano fatto un po di economia e se devi
venderlo dove c'è la tizia che ti dà la
c'è le quest e degli animali dove la
tizia delle come questi animali possa
permanere dove lavora dove si ma io mi
chiamo non lo capisco
poi c'è la venda del primo giorno oddio
rega potete il comprare la la felpa e la
felpa la benda
che costa un gol de e forse tra due
perché ormai quale è giusto ti danno la
fe lab la benda del day one
te lo puoi comprare il resto della birra
canzo generico deve vendere stesse
spesso anche la prima che è che non sia
più deve chiaramente dire queste cose
dove sei ore
io comunque sono quanti nomi puoi
comprare in sto gioco è stata la chiamo
dino di scoprirla copre di tuttora non
capisco dove sia questa mercante eccone
sopra fino all ascom bologna barba
vorrei fino al 20 set
fino al 26 barbe pranzi a un bar ma ci
sono anche le missioni dovete bisogna
combattere contro gli scheletri mai le
prendo eh sì a proposito quella del
teschio è una quest che si sblocca e mi
sa che non so come come sbloccarla però
molti di alcuni della ciotti mi dicono
che si guarda quanto sabato omi massimo
ci ha dato mio e le scienze la ragazza
lei spe regalo e ha capito niente d'oro
buttato nel cesso le spezie le troviamo
le spese i pomodori le fiamme di 140.000
che persona interna nave oddio sul modo
tra i 21 e si vede alla mercante qua a
destra dalla carta del molo mammamia
1100 questi cali del resto maria cento
signoris pre peroncino mais usa si sta
seguendo aspettative di vita allora fan
a bure ha tagliato e fa una barra brava
mozzarella marina fine poi ora che
magari usciamo e facciamo un pò in cui
andiamo fieri tutti nel signore per sor
comunque notato che le armi non mi si
non ci sono sull'isola
no le armi no non riesco ad equipaggiare
l'arma sull'isola natura quindi alla
fine è semplicemente sull'isola non puoi
più fare i gruppi e corretto credo di sì
perché prima potevi fare piu visto nella
beta adesso mi sa che non può più farlo
perché non mi sblocca popolare però se
gli spari dall'analisi sai qua sto
sparando che ha sparato almeno mi si
sbloccano le armi zullino ragazzi dove
forse arrivare a 140.000 d'oro sino
allora niente ho detto una cavolata sono
io che sono un po pagato
vabbè ma si tanto al day one vedi
cambiato vive di ragazzi dobbiamo
vendere pietro prima riguarda che madoka
apprende sta roba
ciari soldi questo passo però questo
preferite erano gratis
di fianco allo store cioè la cassa è ma
non vogliono spendere se gli dicevo di
alcol entro per ogni signore regate che
qui fuori qui phonak allora allora
riguarda fine della maglia ho aperto ci
avevo già ma non ne potevo andare
l'altro portiere a sinistra ha vinto a
portare gli indumenti ottimo ma per fare
ricanta mai sono nudo era nudo prima so
se pensato nudo non me lo riferì sexy
insomma è bellissimo lo voglio mettere
io non puoi toglierti lo quello che mi
piace neanche tu ce l'hai è nel senso no
c'è chi è casuale tra l'altro bellissimo
e vorrei mettermi questo ripeto poi
poiché grazie pietro puoi toglierti nyon
ma ce n'è anche tu ce l'hai grazie e lo
so vorrei vorrei che dopo gli esiti
perché voglio farlo solo la poverta
il capitano capitano lorenzo fra i j
allora dall'altra parte dell'isola c'è
una nave ragazzi c'è una nave fermare a
questa parte ci stanno per saltare
velocissimi alla nave
remo si raga corriamo corriamo la nostra
velocissima che assaltano vi ammazzo
tutti come i fichi stanno scrivendo
stanno scrivendo le la chat calma i
think it's classi a dieci storie
rimettere canzoni che non possono essere
inediti e dall'altra parte dell'isola
esattamente dall'altra parte se io non
mangio una parola sono morto tirate su
come fatto pace o sono ancora ragazzi
via via via via baghlan e aiutaci resca
aspetta che vorremmo già una banana
risolverli con una fiera perché no
aspetta il signor velluto specializzato
chiesto armide
gira gira gira gira gira il giappone c'è
la gente che sta scrivendo quindi non si
sono forse accordi ancora a sinistra la
sinistra si assiste veloce facciamo devi
girare un po prima per cacciare nella
marina 110 dire tira anche triste
mettiamo ma ci mettiamo allora ripiano
su giriamo
ma immaginiamo subito di fronte al nuovo
elemento raga abbiamo facendo genetica
stiamo facendo un cd coda lasciate che
il teschio da 5000 e oro
sto di fronte a noi ancorati ragazzi di
distruggerli più a sinistra pietro non è
che è un tappo domanda cioè che ha messo
stampa cantano ai mutamenti a saltarli
ri copyright quindi non avremo nessun
problema si sono guardati non ho dubbi
vai di litri quanto possono indurre uno
in mare e orari anche momento epico e
arrivato il lunario dentro di noi che ci
siamo ei miei cavalieri già fatto con
tacchi male a prenderli mi sa che sono
anche a fondo me lo trovo io vorrei
sparargli ma non mi faceva per
l'attenzione ci penso adesso tanto ci
esalta tranquillo emilio fois gelava
nikon fatto a spaccarmi prima come fatto
sbagliarmi largo per lui dato un ottimo
forza ragazzi uccidiamolo carico il caso
assalto è sotto di te che è sotto di te
lino guardando i forzieri ricaricando la
scusa ma forse questo era il compagno
forziere non gli manca niente se ti
frega niente no allora affondiamo di non
avere comunque affondiamo c'era perché
portiamo gli hano via vorrei vorrei
menarli ma non rischiamo rilasciata alle
di caricare così in coperta abbiamo
nelle palle di una riga coperti tiro
dobbiamo dire tutti i cittadini oggetti
ragazzi dalle scienze alle casse paraico
parlare ottimo perché non mi si sbaglia
mai venite da me ne vado a prendere
dealer le assegna
e che ci ha colpiti dormi e pietro
quello hai fatto bene ma no ma prima di
affondarla rubiamo di le palle di
cannone generale recuperiamo no chissà
che ha fondato la lega ti prego quindi
volta che lo colpisce una notte diversa
ok ma è andata alla lega ma prima che
prima che scompaia prendiamo gli hill e
robben o troppo tardi ci pensa che ci
pensi ci credete
credo mi sa che mi sa che non è stato un
piacere ma con i se non vuoi come fa la
magia sapesse ma vero
ma si sa se lui bordo ciao ragazzi e
bene ok andiamo
[Musica]
e musica inquietante ragazzi sta
passando sotto di noi ho quasi paura
c'è un relitto la nostra destra ma
abbiamo affrontato una nave di caprera
terra quindi ciò che è partita questa
che andiamo a prendere navi che se ne
troviamo teoria dovremmo andare ma il
teschio lo puoi vendere subito teschio
vale ciò che era col cavolo qualcuno
vada a vedere il teschio di questo
spicchio fammi vedere se si vende starò
la quale io vi ho dato messo una
missione con i teschi magari c'entra
qualcosa con dove dobbiamo andare a fare
non c'è più cupi negli avamposti e
questo lo chiamano non più presa dopo i
pupi questione anche i punti vabbè però
nel sito non puoi sparare alla gente
proprio non va beh ma allora riescono a
tirare la polita 9
secondo voci arriva fino al realizzo se
mi sparo col cannone da qua
ok funzione che se ci butta giù
dov'è che si vendeva la roba la famiglia
delle sette mesi dopo siamo
no non lo posso vedo cosa più fare
quindi con te la sedia forse dal titolo
della tesi prima non è un aspetto smetto
si metta buon duto 592 592 che cadevano
dati delle spezie che infatti valgono
più le si mette male ma con miele spi
non valeva poche what va bene io direi
che andiamo a caccia
ora vi prego dobbiamo distruggere un
altro noi perché ha implementato la mia
sun board non lo sono per vacanza
andiamo per per favore
non spoilerare andiamo andiamo dietro e
aspetto abbiamo tutti ecco ottimi
perfetto aspetta che se partita in tre a
due errori
insomma dietro pietro sul proprio allora
tiri ma sono tutt ora andiamo arrivo sta
tirando sul ancora signore paro paro e
lentissimo veramente tira sull'angolo da
soli ma indicando di primati e tra le
parti è la cosa più lenta
[Musica]
il moto di rivoluzione di giove credo
che sia più veloce pluralità di fronte a
noi e poi vediamo chi c'è in zona al
momento direi che siamo telescopio
ingaggiamo lega non aspetta un
cannocchiale verso un no per qualcosa
il momento ragazzi è il momento il
momento di uccidere tutti ragazzi cosa
fare una cosa ci diamo tutte le luci per
farci venire ad attaccare almeno quello
accendiamo tutte le luci della nave ma è
esatto tutte le luci accese dobbiamo far
capire chi siamo dove siamo e che
vogliamo allora siamo noi abbiamo le
vele sono a posto signora i marinai le
cariche le palle di cannone caricare
andiamo altezza l'aga fatto tutti si sta
vantiamo
a me non dispiace rischio temerario e
pietro che è contrariato andrebbe
rivolta riferivo fare un po di più cupi
queste cose pericolose
ok andiamo al tecnico
andiamo a questo sì se amo al teschio
vai a morire così cambiamo ha poi saremo
della dentro dentro teche occhio che il
destino ha infatti abbassato le tante
come struttura è presente la direzione
di fernando pietro ecco l'altra perché i
ragazzi non è non è esattamente dei
ragazzi
non è che se riuscendo la malfa perché
ho paura che tra poco arriva diventa al
mare rosso tensione tiratrici
un'occhiata vedo nulla di fronte a noi
ci pensa che lo so prenderemo
mettete le velature di di ventura
cortesia non quell'altro ops stavano
uscendo dalla mappa monti e vele
praticamente siamo contro vento però
adesso che è l'origine del girato girate
ottimo visto cosa c'entra la mappa
eccolo lì ottimo non diamo tranquilli
ragazzi ci penso io
ottimo ottimo o loro e questa la gira di
qua che suonando lo sta facendo
signori e non solo sulla barca ragazzi
non posso essere io come non c'è sulla
barca persone allora è come le richieste
proprio sei proprio un burlone
andiamo a segnare ma che abilmente in
prigione ma ne vale più del 3 di guardia
da parte di quelle due volte potrebbe
durare più del previsto e dare così curo
a a pepe si sia ne riusciamo a ridestare
che brutto mamma bastava l'esterno non
lo vedo dove sta caricando
ma io vedo nero c'è proprio un anno la
canzone triste per fare per no no no no
no completa me no quando 98.000 esatto
questo d'ore prima che la prigione la
prigione veramente più brutto ecco
abbiamo un problema ma in cima per
lasciarsi qualsiasi monet una banana
sono larghissime michael scofield spetta
rotolarci ser valore credo che ti
servono assolutamente seri buttate fuori
posto
non posso rivelarlo jack non può e la
pena minima prima che tu stasera
rilasciato ottimo deve rimanere lì
pronto se la pena minima quadro è
originario come regalarsi mi stai
facendo
come non te li vale ancora hai tirato la
qual cosa succede cosa sta succedendo
di solito quello statuto bene stiamo la
nave lo staff successivamente affondando
no no no no no no il teschio dobbiamo
assolutamente tirare fuori i lori della
prigione ma vediamo se ora si può
a noi spetta no non si può ancora lori
secondo di sempre termine del teschio e
tu sei in prigione a posto pochino più
essi non esiste tra la sinistra si sta
girando sto girando attimo dei temi
quanto vi dico io
i più di più di più di più a dipiù ok
allora ancora così conti ha
continuamente la vostra posta da questa
però storia andiamo di nuovo via
maggiore va bene ma viene tranquilla
siamo di mezzo dell'ex delle botti non
ci dovrebbe non ci stanno dando calo
aver proposto ragazzi depositi mi piace
potreste rivolta per il rilascio o che
ora possiamo arrivo stiamo entrando è
siamo esterno del teschio guai nate le
spade tenteranno ora un pochino più a
destra andiamo velocissimi bene bene
tematica non ex post hotel fiore e mi
sono vista di simili
ci si sposta fatto prima di cambiare ma
siamo sicuri che siamo un partito che si
e tedeschi e la nostra destra ma è
esposto prima d'altronde noi abbiamo
dovuto evitare questo scoglio gigantesca
da quando il punto però si sta muovendo
ok e ragazzino onde alte 25 metri in
quanto posto però un perfetto così
perfetto come evento non ce l'aveva
dentro il teschio vuole sapere the
indigente a sinistra farmi stare a
sinistra ma siamo se si può vedere
qualcosa non si sa cosa ci stia lì
dentro dover scendere al teschio chi sta
guidando lega guidando io sto creando i
ok
egli ha purtroppo non la vedevo che
resta un esterno che era ora ma per
certe l'essere siamo linea che
perfettamente si ok sfidare la regola
ok si no
siamo ok ci siamo ma ma si muove vero
perché è lontanissimo scusa
semplicemente ma infatti ora gli occhi
sono rossino più verdi ha regalato e non
c'è una nave a nave di fronte a noemi 6
nella guardò rega non è rivelato
esattamente se stiamo iniziale princi
reagire a destra e lega destra di nico e
di quanto poi così intercettiamo anche
fondiamo le variabili al cento per cento
tu continua è un pochino perché hanno le
vele spiegate vanno anche loro dice ok a
posto così a posto così che controsterza
sinistra e mai io possa essere successo
dolori perché si sono tutti ma perché il
numero rimane comunque signore gas era
una cosa farci anche un'altra nave di là
più appena arrivati si è chiaramente non
aveva fatto nomi cari a nord nord ovest
guardala bus a nord ove si è la nostra
sinistra davanti a noi a sinistra e 9
quali essi ne siamo ancora lì ok
programma il rischio doveva scuote
regolamenti ma stiamo andando verso un
autobus nel caso di guardare non c'è
nessuno alla comoda york poi guardate se
queste sono sei un out post quello
perché non mi sa che siano man posto
sempre sono proprio fermi o stanno solo
su un'isola è il momento di ucciderli a
nord
chi per vanity fair e se di ladri
scheletri sempre al nord loro la giusta
direzione che non vedo le vele quadri
che sembra interessata ma a quanto sò
dovrebbe essere tv l'isola p 10
noi come altri contro l'isola
no non lo so dovremo provare
copriamo lo la mia idea la faccia non mi
piace proprio tanto copriamo lo
scopriamo quindi arriviamo noi puntiamo
ai pirati avversari
e siamo ai pirati avversari no perché
voglio decidere tutto il più possibile
sa non diamo e facciamo tutto magari
proviamo a votare la provate a votare
per il viaggio così a caso per vedere se
abbiamo anche la missione lì non ho mai
messo sul tavolino l'omessa la mozione
del partito la casa da k perché si
chiama ho messo la missione degli
scheletri regga su temi sono gettate
dovuto accettarlo che ha ragione vera
ragione aspetta che stava dormendo qua
ma leggermente simil tral di arrivo
eccolo votato ok bene combattimento con
una ciurma patetica della nike lei di
vediamo se quella giusta ma che funziona
guardate la mappatura premuto rete
premuto e ragazzi sono due navi locale
che li prendiamo quello di sinistra
prendiamo vediamo quella di sinistra si
sente premuto e guardate la cosa con
targa addio la ricerca è sempre nascosto
nel teschio nelle ossa
ok con i suoi paletti la leggenda per
aver protetto il posto io ti prego prego
dopo dvd
disabilitati in una sola vela un pochino
ma guardava dove le manovre per avere la
barca delta gasperoni amo è così
divertente quel modo solo in mano guarda
facendo così ti aiuta un pochino le mani
carichi sì sì sì sì sì un occhio dei sì
sì per madonna perfetto beni che bravo
che sono per farci medici vedi più o
meno che guarda l'orizzonte l'errore
a casa bellissima ragazza sono fermi
quindi uccidendosi
monitoriamo no andiamo andiamo a chi sa
che siamo siamo veramente vicini
all'isola
sì credo che sia quella la donna che è
questo risulterà più pietro facciamo
bene ovvio che facciamo in modo va bene
fino sapessimo di scudi di pietro lui
indro metodo che già operavano saluta
ciao
ecco fallo mentre ci stiamo per
schiantare ti prego fallo di per gli oli
picchio rosso ma perché non riesco a
tirare fuori l'arma tutti i cannoni sono
carichi e siamo pronti oddio ragazzi
esalto soprattutto regala ancora sono
protetti occhio ci arriva proiettile in
faccia mi ha fatto malissimo però ce
l'hanno caricato di coordinamento
regionale
un abito che ogni anno credibile ma come
ti stavo andando alla grande mi serve
una mano a tirar via l'acqua reso un
finito nell'acqua
anzi a dire il vero ma ancora tanto bene
perché è una vigilia colpire bravi ho
visto un bel pezzo di beni e servizi
disparate anche potreste riuscire a
votare perché stiamo imbarcando acqua
200 all'ora mi servono chemical
scaricare sta riparando
io non ho il secchio mi sono consultato
anche quindi e pregano in alto la nostra
nave sta affondando squali più nemici
non è proprio connubio perfettibile sto
salvando la sua salvando ragazzi ora
quel giudizio richiesto qua non ci sono
o ci sono non ci sono io non sono molto
bene va bene va bene va bene va bene
diciamo così la leggenda per aver
protetto civardi e quindi ragazzi c'è
tommy ad esso stesso salvo andò salvando
la nave tranquilli o ha riparato tutto
ci sono tizio best o scaricando l'acqua
forza
ragazzi io mi ritrovo nell'aldilà
insieme a quelli che avete ucciso
dobbiamo andare a prendere l'oro e
timidi su cannone proprio gli spari
verso la loro nave fossimo un po lontani
mista scalta adesso riesco a tirare
fuori le armi perfetto
tiriamo sull'area rami posso giocare e
tiriamo sul ancora fonti ordine viale su
sì che sono carico persona che viaggia
in mente dietro di noi dalla alcuno
della nave mia mondiale poi come te non
è più vestiti ragazzi ancora imbarcando
acqua se è vero solo lui in panchina
perché non abbiamo tolto pulsando di
assolo aspetta che collegano si è recato
abbiamo rilevato tutto tirando via però
bisogna anche girare la lana se siamo
malamente a parole come segue citando i
tranquilli voi poi riparate le beta
chiamo li ho pagati
anche perché è mentale vedere se li per
vistare un chilometro ma che il colpo
perché colto qualche colpo guardalo no
per niente nel nulla dopo un po troppo
veloci mi sa che andremo a sbattere
contro la viola ancora ancora una volta
la sicurezza si stanno muovendo quindi
l'ancora che tirate ma saremmo andati a
sbattere contro l'isola ok niente
riuscirò mette colpi in canna loro
ragazzi da ricaricare i cannoni ok
quando al timone ci colpiscono ci
colpiscono ci colpiscono zio non ci
hanno preso non ci andavo più bello i
rapidi laterale bravissimi maria alla
pietra e sto carica ci penso io
al momento ragazzi sprono questi no no
no ora disperiamo da infarto o meglio ma
che cavolo ciò in mano la pistola il
marinaio
mamma mia oh oddio e beccatevi questo
insieme attenzione scarsi vogliamo fare
questa cosa vogliamo fare niente chiaro
richiamo lamentiamo la semi sparate
sulla nave ferrari aspettate
quindicenne colpiti c'è un bottino di
girare il vento era un po di più siamo
ancorati non possiamo stormi butta
dentro la palla migliore che serve è tra
il canone mai sparato la nave sparami al
momento 32 puro aspetta che si ok
vai a chi li ho presi
porca vacca che ti sono tornato arriva
dal maturati ci salgo sto tirando via
l'acqua io pietro che credete che mi
abbiano visto ragazzi mente all'ultimo
sangue
scott i giudici stanno facendo una morta
una volta due martino fattibile se
dovrei massimo affondare
stiamo affondando ragazzi sono pronti
stiamo andando giù da teli cerati
secchielli raga io ho fatti fuori
infatti fare venite qua veniva fondato
da te non siano fondati prima molte
casse di legno come si fa si farà ora
che si parla come si parlano
luca così cara ti sto andando verso di
loro sta andando il break il break il
boot ed il ancora finché ancora gli ha
fregato nave legando o che magari
arriviamo arrivando ci hanno affondato
la nostra l'ora o mio dio hanno dei
tesori tiragli l'ancora gara dei ragazzi
alla fine gara che non abbiamo un altro
9 dietro ai ragazzi problema che adesso
mi restavano abbiamo rubini tesoro
buttati in acqua scappiamo nostra è una
città su una volta aia previste
solamente sarro sticazzi va bene va bene
sapete c'è una squadra bottino delle
ragazze ma basta mantenere il mio ci
sono tizio o è stata l'azione più bella
della vita gli abbiamo fatto i ragazzi
stavano venendo incontro 23 squali
ho paura ho paura posto ragazzi io sono
con una sono con un forziere attaccata
alla loro nave nessuna mia mais
pregato sulla loro barca insomma io sono
buono mordere cioè mi hanno ucciso
non porto anch'io tra questa sei
bellissima sono ancora vivo sott'acqua
lontanissimo col forziere glielo sto
soltanto rubando così per portare di noi
avevano solo quello quindi hai portato
via l'unico forziere che avevano ci sono
quattro squali intorno a me è morire
almeno lievi dei fatti hai fatto per le
forse ero io quando ha messo paura per
stato il loro non sono i migliori
e stato bello babe per una come una
vittoria giuro per me va benissimo e
com'eravamo parlare perché tu sei morto
ok che si sono morto adesso si fa uno
che parte 7 ma posso dormire anche
nell'aldilà lo ha spronato posso dormire
anche nell'aldilà
oddio il mare per tutti ok e mare ci
unisce così a dormire ok se ti si
ritrovano fra le onde tutti i membri
della ciurma sono uguali lascio per mano
legale legami inviolabile rispetto ai
nuovi pirati il loro viaggio l'oritano
rispettino i pirati no perché ci stanno
sparando a chi imbroglia verrà punito
con l'uomo allora non sto leggendo il
codice di pirati e precisamente il
concittadino ragazzi scusate ma siete
voi racchie lo straniero misterioso
tanta rabbia ma da qua vedo un altro
nave raga io volendo se rispondete tutti
ripartiamo c'è il giusto andiamo andiamo
andiamo a verona per bonato andiamo jack
farlo che farà per devo innanzi alle
altre due navi che si combattono davanti
a moena ma se le sparate facciamo il
terzo in questo processo a bordo carico
i cannoni manca pietro carico e pronto a
noi prima arriva però da sparare arrivo
delegati cannoni aiutano dietro i dati
tutti forza forza forza
sosteniamo l'olio tempo per capire che
in realtà correndo la cosa più terribile
che violante e mi impegno presso loro
carica palla di carbone il pezzo davanti
a noi erano quindi sono ancora quindi se
tiri giù con tutti carichi di rai
ecco il lobbistico fisico ma è stato
bello riuscire a fare fuori una nave
allora
sì non so dove siano però mi fido
però quello che dico io secondo me non
aveva colpito in diversi punti per
affondare le si fossero alla base alla
base alla base dove c'era il padre per
la madre ammette cercare che tutto 6.49
adobe allora davanti a noi fa aspettato
dico io vado su sull'albero victor
andremo scappando cioè stanno dalla
parte opposta sto andando no no no non
scappano non scappano perché riteniamo
un vecchio e che sta suonando così se un
primato che semmai aumento al gioco e
sta tornando dopo i acque bruttissima la
canzone ubriaco
ciao ragazzi abbiamo due navi davanti
prevedo dall'alto
no non faccio come faccio a riprendermi
prima mi dovevo fare l'acqua torni per
favore dai che schifo
grazie storm e non voglio commentare
questa scena siete tutti i ii iii di
patti guardi non ho capito schifo
vabbè dai raga riusciti a girare le
belle e india facciamo lo faceva in saio
da ubriachi veloce
perché mirate in cui un verso testa
nelle vele con un vero regalo non vedo
io
davanti a noi c'è un ci sono degli
scogli no se magari non guardare a
destra allora se guardassi ci passa ci
mette un passo simile scogli
basta in mezzo agli sbagli inter
programmata el'altra nale mezzo stice
colle ci sono altre isole tender molto
piano
ema pietro legambiente si meno di
capitan ora in ora chissà che non ci può
sempre stare e mezzo tranquilla ci pensa
di stare da me da ministra pietro
sinistra come dice alteration altri ma
se devo difendere la quale da allora
difficile riuscire a passare è finita è
finita si sono fatte statale galileo
ma allora ricco dritto dritto così la
nostra cena pietro sella a sinistra
velocissimo a sinistra velocissimo
bravissimo ora tutto adesso che non ci
fu ucciso resto adesso tutto è destro
veloce tutto a destra tutto destra anni
tutta la strafiga di beton guidati meno
rigido e sinistra
allora niente ma estrema sinistra
sionista che ormai è troppo tardi troppo
tardi continua si sta tranquilli in
extremis ma troppo tardi
[Musica]
spero che sarebbe andato a vivere con
vero sofferma anche fisicamente agli
uccelli bene tutte e tre adesso che a me
ti prego vieni ad averlo indotto a
carico o se parlava da chi ha messo
tutte e tre le vele a sinistra e io
perché no perché ho seguito ho seguito
il mio capitano di spiegare le vele per
avere questo nuovo cd terrore triste
triste triste
va bene perché raccapricciante questo
momento guarda che siamo arrivati e che
bisognava andare vabbè ormai una
strisciante comunque va beh un po vedere
intorno ma l'acqua dopo che poi quando
tutto quando tutto ragazzi c'è una nave
per vicinissima a noi di si quella
quella direzione ovest ma totalmente da
prendere siano tiriamo simile nelle vele
fa retromarcia
no no no siamo strani aiutatemi ad avere
sistematicamente bull ancora contro il
muro davamo io ma era troppo tardi
contro lanciata forza mai detto fai
vedere dove la lele e lory
ecco a sinistra ecco ecco la vedo a
destra anche ne abbiamo ora un elettrodo
finito per le trovi picchia duro e ovest
e la direzione che dovremo andare quindi
devi girare meglio fare meglio arrivarci
facendo sempre bene el bati di te la
dico giusta è scusami e nord e nord
dietro perdonami regala i primi dati di
me p e non daranno abbiamo fare tre esse
non c'è donavano e un primo che tocca le
vele tutt'al di dei mali giuro
ricordo quando devo andare più veloci
girone vede raga tranquilli è che ho
fatto l'ho vinto giuliano giu ok c'è
all'avamposto ragazzi dei ragazzi state
vicino a destra le belle cose il western
destra vai pietro destra vai ancora
ancora destra ancora ancora temi
controllo live aid invierà raccomandiamo
qua raccomandiamo veloci ora pietro
mi pare così e questo tanto come dici di
girarla ancora di più a destra
bastava dirlo pietro un'altra nave
lontano è siamo approcciati
quell'avamposto ma la traversa ragazzi
quella giusta mica possiamo uccidere
chiunque vi preoccupate arriva arriva in
un problema
ecco la musica perfetta ok siamo pronti
al combattimento giusta nella direzione
pietro dream o in cornaglia dai
torneremo a fare tutto partendo ragazzi
se noi inseguiamo li può essere che
siano ripartiti sono i partiti sono
ripartiti presenza di incornarlo pietro
ragazzo lo verso di noi tra ma non a
norma stone da una pagina della
dell'isola quindi vai a destra pietro
giriamo perché diciamoci a destra ma
dietro non sono andati sono dietro di
noi anticipiamo poiché tenersi un po
pietro serve legittimi servo le casse
tom tu devi tirare devi mettere le video
si apre il libro quando rientro di
rigore dritto triple 6 tutte dritte le
vere signore in giro pochino più ora
stiamo andando a destra a sinistra
invece prendiamo da verso sinistra
vai vai pietro e il momento momento
pietro che gm sono oggi da me né quello
centrato pasto a caiolo
ok allora vai dritto to pietro vai
dritto così
riprendiamo in pieno così li prendi
esatto ragazzo occhio che questo è stato
un bambino di pietro se ticino anche
quella davanti andiamo ancora più veloce
non è meglio by gira però davanti su che
rimaniamo ancora prima dai ragazzi o mio
dio cosa sta per accadere
ok siamo
il santo è il momento sono poi la musica
della sconfitta all'arrembaggio giu
magari gli scogli scogli con secondo
disco riguardato il mio occhio che che
non ci sono
occhio che ci possono imparare anche noi
siamo rivolti per il momento vai vai al
momento sì ma ragazza pare che non non
ci becchiamo
secondo me
non li becchiamo quei due forza ragazzi
questo per te pietro
ecco allora
[Musica]
ok basta vedere le eventuali o un
elemento si riempie le seguiamo
oddio che spetta ad ogni attimo storico
devo concentrarmi di brutto però gli
intenti ha sentito rumori aveva ma
secondo me stanno non vogliono
approcciarci stanno scappando
beh quello intuito però noi di
approcciare storico al limite mi spari
sopra tanto vedi che funziona o
chiocchio avete girato sia assolutamente
si abbiamo il premier caso di schifo ma
che no non ci andiamo all'isola quella
dato il destro per chi suona un pick pay
tv della contesa ma c'è il moschetto
come arma attenzione si può mettere
social cecchino per fa come il check in
e comprato un po me no è sotto nella
stiva potete averlo anche voi cecchino
basta mettere nella casa delle armi che
c'è nella stiva è il momento di prendere
il cecchino forse del 90 per
equipaggiamento sotto sopra dove fare
ricaricate le munizioni ragazzi
dell'arma archibugi maniero non sono le
migliori armi scambiare sì poi la vuoi
mettere a posto la pistola o della spada
puoi avere anche due armi non si fermano
questi qua sto provando a girare
lamentano dei tesori se continuano a
scappare
l'archivio va che figata tutti ragazzi
straniero stragrande
variabile vedere delle belle che mi sono
già sono già pronte a sé ma non curiamo
mai così non copriamo lo dico forse va
bene ora prende ancora meglio le opere
eseguite seguito divenne frolle vele
essi sanno potreste provare a sparare
troppo distanti la regione non ci
facciamo troppo lontano dobbiamo
avantaggiarsi poco andremo contro
vendola ma quanto leverà le mangrovie
passera non l'hai mezzo secondo voi ce
la fa ce la metti milito datemi anche
buona ma la sentiamo sicuri e come le
verità energetico ieri pietro non vedi
giri delle dritte e all'altro imboccò
centrale procura adesso primo giro così
a patrasso 1
anche i tank basta così basta così ma
quella è l'avamposto di prima
vediamo se mi sei dove sei morti 9 se ti
giri a destra pietra mi sparate in alto
che ci arrivano secondo me ora che
giriamo il tuo arrivi troppo lontano
va beh ma se un millimetro che li
perdiamo se facciamo solo quando
pronunciarli via aver vero essere unioni
tra qui solo contro penso convegno mesi
ci per rip
diamo peso né avamposto poi sicuramente
vanno a consegnare dei tesori tranquilli
per capelli che devono andare tanto la
live rimanere sul canale anche se non la
vedete tuta potete rifiutare anche se
potreste effettivamente restare però
attenzione se uccidi qualcuno così ti
giuro
certo ti perché escono è sempre abbiamo
gli occhi si tratta di ragazzi cinema
sinistra intercettiamo si dà ok tirari
esista grinta cerchiamo subito grande
hanno fatto la cagata più grande nella
loro vita la gara finisce volavamo
incontro io sentiamo sognerebbe di
squadre loro siti rassina ancora qua
perche prevenzione usciamo dalla mappa
affondiamo un tetto insieme al 118
cerchiamo lontani dalla fine della mappa
era ancora dire ancora prova spararvi
era ancora gira gira gira gira gira
carica ei vele subito che devo farci un
favore di vento a favore di vento ma
siamo a si mostra sin 40 squadre che ha
risposto siamo lenti siamo lenti se
ancora ce l'hanno una mira questi è ora
che la sinistra ha ci arriva ora cava
questo lei lo sapeva già ripreso piero
sono forti
rega ancora lo presi lo presi lo presi
usa li ha presi nuovo amici sono tirati
rami dentro le prese ancora il tremendo
aspetto ragazzi vuoi saltarci dentro ti
voglio provare la posso fare
non ci arriviamo sa che vai vai tu a me
vai tono 30.000 non troppo perché anche
a me anche adesso con questo mio dio
storia mi sparano sono salito buongiorno
ragazzi poi danno tom fi danno tommy
devi usare anche la sciabola occhio che
con lo sciopero devi anche parare i
colpi 1 e ucciso preciso uno di 100
rassina vai gettare l'ancora qualcuno
cercherà il timore chi è che al timone
pietro vai sulla nave immediatamente
ogni anno tirata nessuno tanto
tranquilli mi hanno buttato giù dalla
nave giratela giu
gela girando stanno provando a tirare su
noi dobbiamo levare l'altro da sotto
traditori l'acqua da sonia non c'è
un'insegnante portiere arriva oggi ogni
casinò casse di legno dobbiamo riparare
buttare giù l'aquila botero fuori
lanciamo lendu ce la fate no che tira
regate copro io le assi a noi avete
loria che poi ho messo un asse però non
so se l'unica perché partiamo troppa
acqua quindi sicuramente c'è un altro
buco che non sto vedendo non vedo dove
ci hanno colpito oltre 4 l'abbiamo perso
dove sia a quel punto siamo cioè a chi
suda è il doppio quello che ho visto il
successo non dovrebbero succedere
stanno provando a spararci nuovo non
volevo numero di carbonati non si vede
siamo tristi davanti a noi hanno tolto
l'ancora sulla destra sulla destra la
nave dobbiamo sparargli dall'essere
anale occhi proietti ci arrivano in
faccia no allora abbiamo un
dove poterlo io ok ok ok vice forza
speriamo speriamo buono questo è buono
ecco perfetto questo come da portare
bene un altro buco non abbondano raga
sono duri a rega quest'anno dopo che
mancato di pochissimo
io non ho visto tre gambe a de nicolo
problema non so perché perché erano di
metterle al club ma dove stanno i
ragazzi di ragazzi guardiamo che non
siano andando fuori dalla mappa loro
perché di affonda la nave in automatico
per spegnere speriamo che sembrano
adesso grande farmi ripara volta
arrivati da tempo fuori di che avevo un
altro buco al secondo piano
il piano intermezzo c'è un altro gruppo
francese e sono un botto di brooklyn per
mezzo che aveva finito a posto ok ottimo
quindi ragazzi frattempo vedere come
siamo messi
ok stiamo inseguendo regali sono fuori
loro sono fuori dalla zona devono
curvare e non andrà il 100
gira gira tutto a destra ignora la loro
direzione
vai a signa fi tutto a sud ignora
ignorare la direzione loro rubarla
eccoli là ok ok allora abbiamo siamo
totalmente controvento devo devolvere
stanno uscendo completamente dalla mappa
ragazze mi sparate vincere vuole vedere
ok ok che si spara temi questi errori
ti sparo aspetto anch'io 36 ore ti sparo
è però pensando che quando siamo vicini
pregati viste negare che ci si reca in
sé come ente di fare
no non ce la fa importante insomma non
li vecchi node i vecchi
che sia diventato di fatto ha fatto
festa perche parte ma poi non ci arrivi
mai possibile agire agire sinistra di
sicilia
oddio oddio oddio per incornare amadio
[Applauso]
sbaglia sbagliato a cava cà cosa come ho
fatto io non ci voglio 13 passa perché
sulle nostre fuori tre inglesi ho
sentito parlare degli inglesi marashi
morti tutte le tre vertici tutti e due
ok bye bye bye bye la l'ancora giu
mancava una pur ragazzi ragionate storia
tirato un colpo di cannone a me per
uccidermi
non si sa perché ucciso era scusato per
le mille e una notte senza guardare la
scienza del capitale è affondata la nave
ma ci sono concini la
rubati cinque le palle di cannone come
siete mondi temi delicati
non è tutto almeno di recuperiamo
chissà che non è regate
e qualità
mi piace
se invece siete morti non siete morti si
devono mettila ti prego è bellissimo è
fatto bello scambio tra le gambe
riacquisto veramente bella e una taglia
prime si chiama registrato nel cisione
era stato rendere il bellissimo so nice
com rivela che due case per auto il
cannone da soprano siamo la loro nave a
questa è la peste loro la loro sirena
giusto o no possono usarla che io che è
stato proprio bello care si son fatte le
dice placido l'arco meglio dire che per
me è ok quindi giusta una bella abbiamo
fatto sette tesori abbiamo preso una
foto di due navi per trento che la
campanella possiamo migliorare e vabbè
abbiamo un diving già miracolo che
abbiamo fatto qualcosa
e niente lagalla facciamo che che se non
c'è se l'importo non mi son profumarsi
ce ne sono
quindi possiamo convivere quattro
ragazzi vi ringrazio per aver superato
anche il gioco che avete visto è si recò
play off ma come si fa a secco prego per
voi
grazie e se il film che avreste capito
io lo sto giocando su xbox l'unics però
c'è anche su pc d'ordine anche con due
successi tra dal cross 3
niente chi però la serie nei prossimi
giorni perché adesso è uscito quindi
usciranno vita manetta sempre con stormi
di pietro
insomma anche se non so se ciò voglio
però se lo obbligherebbe bene bene
l'importante è uccidere gli altri
conoscesse è nulla raga per chi non ha
visto lo avesse visto l'inizio dai voti
non ha visto alla fine la juve rimane
sul canale quindi direi che possiamo
davvero ottimo cielo si scende quando
davanti era entrato armi che si è seduta
non posso passare riprende la musichetta
se non rispettava aspetta aspetta
aspetta
ecco tutto
la fonte non basta grazie
e sai perchè davanti entrato nel
capitano l'entrata il capitano che sulla
grata
non vorrei dire niente ma ok chiedo
anch'io dar al hikma visto che non
tirarla ancora no non direi per motivi
grazie a queste alla mano che lavora
come visto cadere ma fatto un modo
bellissimo e mi avverti che nessun
artista cubano to see me la sto portando
lo sa bene
basta direi che posso chiudere a daytona
notte ragazzi ci sederemo saremo ciao
ciao ragazzi io non so chiude con tre
cose